hey guys Pete here I'm guessing that
everyone's seen the new game of thrones
season 8 trailer the first full-length
trailer we got with season 8 footage it
actually came out I lived in Vietnam so
it came out like right as I was laying
in bed I got a notification and it was
from the YouTube channel Game of Thrones
saying that there was an official
trailer so I couldn't sleep for a while
thinking about that and today I've been
working on some Game of Thrones content
and I decided that rather than making a
trailer breakdown since there's probably
already a bunch of those out there that
I would look at some of the other stuff
does this actually tell us much as far
as things we didn't already know the
hype train has definitely left the
station at this point the night before
last I saw the James Hibbard stuff come
out right before bedtime in that article
we learned a lot more about the shooting
and they're really serving up the Battle
of Winterfell on a platter as far as not
trying to keep that a secret they made
it clear that it's going to be the third
episode it's going to be the longest
cinematic action sequence ever recorded
it's going to go on for over 40 minutes
which is pretty insane in and of itself
and we know that all the major
characters for the most part are going
to be there the trailer is definitely
exciting the idea of this super long
battle is definitely exciting but it's
interesting that they're being so
upfront about that considering that
there has to be a lot more that happens
in this season to make it satisfying if
we already know about the big battle I
think it's safe to say that all of what
we see here is from the first three
episodes there may be a short sequence
or two in there that are from later but
nothing of consequence that stands out
and frankly not much that shows us how
that battle is decided which is good I
mean that's the drama right but most of
what we see is the pre game and the
battle scenes that we actually see are
really kind of dark and hard to make out
and we don't really see the dead much at
all so let's talk about what we don't
see what that might mean what I really
found interesting about this and then
you guys can all decide what you thought
was interesting and tell me about that
in the comments first major character
that we don't see in this trailer goes
back to what I was just saying that we
don't see the dead much we don't see
whites we don't see white walkers and we
definitely don't see the night king or
Viserion in this trailer there's no
question as to what the threat to
Winterfell is so that we don't really
need to see that that's a great reveal
to see in the actual episode right but
it's still notable that we only see one
side in this two-sided battle another
main character that we don't see is
Theon and that's pretty easily explained
in that I assume that Theon is gonna do
what he said he was gonna do and he's
gonna go try to save Yara Euron actually
plays a role in this trailer and
delivering the golden company to Cersei
and that has to happen first before
Theon can do anything - you're on
another character that's missing here
that I feel like is going to play a big
part in the end game is Melisandre we
don't see any hint of her or her
influence on the preparation for the
battle I don't think it's gonna happen
but you know I just like everybody I
think that knows who the fiery hand are
and what they look like I'm hoping to
see them but I don't know that they're
going to definitely play a part
however Melisandre is an important
character I do think she has a part to
play in this battle if she shows up with
the thousand soldiers wearing orange
robes and red
armorer that'd be great but regardless I
think it's interesting that she's not in
this at all and that that might mean
something about how she makes an
entrance also we don't see ghosts we
don't see Nymeria although I imagine if
Nymeria and her Wolf Pack show up that
would be in the middle of the battle
rather than you know they'll come and
line up with everybody in the beginning
or something like that but we do know
that ghost is going to be back and I
expect that he'll play a part in the
battle but none of the shots with John
that we see here actually have ghosts
involved in them that's really it for
all the characters that we don't see
everyone else is pretty much involved in
these different clips
besides Theon this could be something
that it's telling us that these players
are all going to play an impactful role
but they don't want to reveal them ahead
of time because that would take away
from their entrance when they do come
with that out of the way I wanted to
talk about the parts I thought were the
most interesting the first of which
being this Aria sequence at the very
beginning of course there's a lot of
great stuff in this trailer an example
is John getting ready to ride Ragle I
mean that is an awesome moment for a
trailer but the Aria sequence is a lot
more interesting to me she's running but
you can't really tell where she's
running to the voiceover is from earlier
like it's from before the battle and we
see her looking really confident and
that's what really stood out is the
contrast there ever since Aria has been
back and on her way back for that matter
from Braavos she's had this really cool
exterior you know like think about
whenever she reunited with hot pie you
know
it was hey yeah okay you got any ale you
know what I mean she's not really been a
frightened child in her interactions say
what you want about the Winterfell
subplot last season but think about her
demeanor think about when she executed
Littlefinger she's come across as this
calculated assassin so you know this is
her first battle we see her fighting
she's got blood on her face when she's
running down this hall so she may have
been injured but the whole idea of like
you know most of what I've read or heard
about this is that she's running from
something
meaning that you know the battle has
turned outside and now she is being
chased which is probably the case and
everything else but it's just a curious
looking scene like where is she going
and what exactly did she see or
experience that made her go from that
new personality that we've seen to
someone who's really genuinely terrified
I think that's interesting I don't know
if it means anything it's pretty likely
that she's heading you know to the
crypts where we saw Varys and others
hiding out with you know Gilly and
everything but it's a pretty interesting
sequence in my opinion I don't know if
you could say it's something we didn't
know obviously and we knew that everyone
would be tested in this situation but it
really emphasizes the reality of that
for me whenever I watch this when you
see Arya here all these other questions
about like what's going to happen when
John finds out is true parentage and
how's Daenerys gonna take it and all
this other stuff that's going on those
things really don't matter in the heat
of this confrontation of course John is
going to be upset we see that here in
the trailer of course that's going to
cause an awkward situation but at the
same time the thing that's hanging over
everyone's heads is a literal battle for
life versus death and that leads me into
the next thing that I thought was really
interesting you know I didn't really
pick this up until after watching it
several times when we hear John talking
about the army of the Dead and the enemy
the others the White Walkers we get that
coupled with Cersei and it jumped out to
me that like they're gonna do this right
in the third episode they're gonna
battle for life for everyone the show
creators everyone that has any idea
about what's going to happen is telling
us that but think about the fact that
even after that is over like one way or
another the White Walkers are going to
be defeated but that's not even the end
of the story after they do this as this
clearly shows in the way that they
edited this trailer Cersei is planning
on wiping them out she's also a
formidable enemy
and she's human the night King and I
think this is what we all were really
gonna ever know about the night king in
the main Game of Thrones series I feel
like we're gonna probably learn a lot
more about who he is and where he came
from and all that when the prequel comes
out but all we've been led to know so
far about his creation and what he does
and what his goals are is that he exists
to destroy humanity in that absolute
sense he's able to get everyone on the
same page to save everyone except for
the humans Cersei and her people that
are trying to use this to their
advantage to retain power and I think
that's really interesting I think
there's a lot of good stuff that can
come out of that after this battle as
far as wrapping up the series I mean who
is the worst enemy I think that is a
good question at this point and I think
it says a lot about humanity and what we
are and who we are and I think that's a
great way to highlight that in this
trailer without giving up too much about
the way the thing ends beyond that I'm
pretty excited I've been working on some
other stuff and I'll have some more
videos coming out and I think they did a
really good job here of stoking up the
hype you know again everyone excited as
to the question that this video asks in
the title though I don't think that we
really did learn anything new nothing
that we didn't already know or couldn't
piece together based on the evidence
from the story or all the press that
they've already put out in my mind this
confirms Jon's gonna ride Greg all he's
definitely gonna find out I mean it's
not just in my mind but he's definitely
going to
not about his parentage they're gonna
have to deal with all that and it's all
leading up to a giant battle in Episode
three but beyond that what I've
mentioned here in this video the Aria
sequence and the Cersei stuff has me
more excited about the overall story
than I thought that I was and I was
pretty excited about it already so
that's a good thing let me know what you
guys think though as I mentioned I have
been working on some other Game of
Thrones content so that'll be coming
over the next few days can dig a little
bit deeper into what's going on and what
we expect to see happen now that we have
the trailer that stuff is gonna be even
a little bit easier to put together I
think there's about 40 days until the
first episode drops I think we'll
probably get one more trailer although I
don't expect that we'll get to find out
too much more about anything beyond this
battle just because of the logistics of
like anything they show after that will
reveal who makes it through the battle
and you understand so it's like you know
if you see later scenes from the season
then that's gonna take away some of the
drama
whenever the actual fighting is going on
so that's why I'm at let me know where
you guys are at I appreciate you
watching and I will talk to you soon